[Musique]
il y aura une partie qui va être sur
notamment sur les problèmes de
rémunération avec un développement sur
l'épargne salariale dans l'entreprise et
puis ensuite il y a une conférencière
qui va venir et qui va parler
de le nom de sa conférence et ce qui
nous lit donc entre les chef
d'entreprise et les salariés c'est
ouvert à toutes les entreprises qui
adèrent au meddef et ceux qui ont envie
de venir pour voir ce qu'on y fait et
rencontrer des chefs d'entreprises qui
sont adhérentss là aujourd'hui on a 140
personnes qui sont inscrites euh donc
bienvenue aux chefs d'entreprise qui
nous qui nous entendent et qui
souhaitent venir rencontrer d'autres
chefs
d'entreprisees le recrutement est un
vrai problème pour les entreprises
aujourd'hui puisqu'il y a plus d'offres
d'emploi que de demande et les salariés
vont faire un peu leur leur shopping
entre guillemets dans les entre
entreprise euh et l'important donc c'est
que les entreprises ne perdent pas les
salariés et fidélisent les salariés qui
sont déjà présents et fidéliseent ceux
aussi qui candidatent pour pour venir
dans les entreprises donc l'enjeu c'est
comment on fait pour s'assurer que les
collaborateurs restent et donc il faut
travailler sur des stratégies de
fidélisation réfléchir à un certain
nombre de leviers pour pour faire en
sorte qu'il se sent bien dans
l'entreprise et qu'ils y
restent les leviers qui sont importants
et pour lesquels les les chefs d'entre
les pardon les salariés attachent une
importance c'est d'abord le télétravail
euh c'est clair que si l'entreprise ne
propose pas de télétravail ça ne va pas
être très très très attirant pour les
salariés c'est devenu une norme depuis
depuis le confinement euh assurer un bon
équilibre vie professionnelle vie
personnelle offrir des perspectives
d'évolution professionnelle offrir un
aussi donner un sens et une valeur au
travail surtout les jeunes sont très
attachés à cela ils veulent que ils
veulent que leur travail serve à quelque
chose ils veulent comprendre quel est le
sens de leur travail ils veulent des
revalorisations régulières des salaires
euh ils veulent des avantages
socioattractifs euh bon environnement de
travail et cetera ils veulent des
formations ils veulent en fait ils
veulent évoluer dans l'entreprise avec
euh une ambiance qui soit une bonne
ambiance euh qui pu puisse y avoir de
l'émulation et où il voit où ils vont
donc il y a des pratiques managériales
modernes qu'il faut mettre en place et
tous ces leviers euh doivent utêre
partagé par le dialogue social et ça les
entreprises maintenant commencent à être
sensibilisé vraiment au dialogue social
c'est mettre les choses sur la table
partager avec les salariés des
perspectives pour eux euh pour le
développement de l'entreprise et ce ce
dialogue social permet de lever un
certain nombre de problèmes qui peuvent
exister euh et puis trouver des
solutions à à ces
[Musique]
problèmes